Connaissez-vous les banques d'images ?
En gros ce sont des sites sur lesquels tu peux trouver pleiiin d'images,
et tu vas pouvoir, en méga HD,
Tu vas pouvoir acheter ces images pour ilustrer tes articles, ou pour faire ta miniature !
Tu vois, si t'as besoin d'un mec qui mange ses crottes de nez,
tu tapes ''mec qui mange ses crottes de nez'' et tu vas trouver ! C'est vrai en plus...
*le cliquetis du clavier accompagne cette recherche*
''Aucun résultat correspondant à ces critères n'a été trouvé''
Bon j'suis peu être un menteur, OK.
BREF, là où je veux en venir,
c'est que ces sites, normalement, comportent des photos qui sont pas trop WTF,  OK ?
Shutterstock, 123 RF, depositphotos, c'est les trois plus gros, je crois...
Moi même je les utilise donc je peux vous dire qu'il n' y a rien de chelou dessus
Et là où je veux en veniiiiir
J'ai trouvé hier un site ...
... Japonais ...
*rire*
Voilà, là vous savez que ça va être bizarre!
Qui s'appelle : "nurse-web.jp"
"Ce site répond à la demande de 1% des clients maniaques des infirmières"
Donc c'est une banque d'images en ligne comme les autres,
Mais c'est QUE des photos d'infirmières, et c'est extrémement bizarre !
Déjà on va les découvrir ensemble,
J'en ai vue deux :
J'ai vue celle avec le coquillage, celle-là, qui n'a aucun sens...
Avec cet homme, qui est en profonde dépression, depuis des années...
Et j'en ai vu une autre,
mais je voulais pas me spoil pour la découvrir avec vous,
Et surtout, on va essayer de trouver des titres à ses images !
Et pour ça Twitter va nous aider, c'est parti !
Donc la y'a rien d'étrange, hein...
À part cet effet loupe ignoble qui n'existe plus depuis 2002 sur internet
Ce que j'aime bien avec ce site, c'est que tu peux télécharger l'image au format téléphone,
Pour que quand tu prends le numéro d'une fille, elle voie ton fond d'écran et elle parte en courant en appelant la police !
Oh Mec, là on commence à être sur du bizarre.
Oh naaan, c'est quoi ?
J'crois que c'est des réservoirs dans lesquels t'es censé uriner...
Bah quand tu peux pas bouger à l'hôpital, Mec t'es content d'avoir, cet objet !
Celle-là j'suis obligé de vous la partager, elle est d'une puissance COLOSSALE!
ALORS!  "Trouvez un titre à cette image"
'' Comment faire des squats'' *rire*
C'est pas mal, j'ai bien aimé.
''Le seigneur des anneaux au Japon'', Je n'ai pas du tout compris la blague.
''Tu ne passera paaasss !!''
''Vous ne passerez pas !''
OK, cette blague a fait l'unanimité,
''Il faudra me passer sur le corps pour que je pisse là dedans!''
Un peu long, mais sympatique!
Alors!
Trouvons une autre image...
OHLALa !?
Mais c'est dépourvu de tout sens ! Pour parler correctement...
Comme cette coupe de cheveux d'ailleurs.
Il y a eu un effort : on est parti de l'hôpital, on a trouvé un katana en chemin. C'est fou.
Suivant!
Oh! une photo normale! Ça fait plaisir!
OH! une photo moins normale...  *rire*
C'est quoi ça !? On dirait les photos-montages de certains la dernière fois, c'est fou !
*les cigales accompagnent ce magnifique montage*
Ah d'accord, donc on a volé une cabine téléphonique pour faire cette photo, très bien.
Oh, mais Mec... Celle-là j'veux qu'vous la commentiez !
Elle est trop belle pour être ignorée
''J'essaye d'avaler une abeille grâce à une paille, ça tourne mal"
*rire*
Oh c'est puissant !
''Aveugle, elle confond son mojito avec une fleur"
Youtunes, ça va pas du tout là !
Dawm it, c'est quoi ?
À mon avis, c'est un ustensile de cuisine.
Et elle vient de lui en mettre sur les cheveux...
*rire*
Hey mais Mec, mais c'est fou !
Ce qui est bizarre, c'est qu'elle le regarde pas, elle regarde ailleurs
Ah, vous allez la commenter celle-là !
"Je m'ennuie donc je poste des photos de chinois sur Twitter !"
Hey je travaille ok, un peu de respect pour les gens qui travaillent !
Et en plus c'est pas des chinois, c'est des japonais, OK ?
P*tain faut tout lui apprendre à Gold Natoun
*rire*
"-Ca sent quoi papa ? -Un manque d'idées de vidéos de la part de Squezzie "
Oh l'b*tard!
*Piou piou piou*
Ah arrêtez!
Bah voilà, il a la punchline de la vidéo.
Tout va nous paraître fade maintenant, après avoir lu cette phrase.
"5 fruits et légumes par jour"
"Mais likez pas les gars c'est même pas drôle" *rire*
Mais arrêtez de vous vanez vous même p*tain, c'était hyper drôle : on a rigolé !
replay quand on a ri : *aha*
Okay mec c'étais que la première page. *rire*
Ah ! Je sait ce que c'étais le truc d'avant : c'était un appareil pour faire de la glace pilée !
Voilà, elle le fait sur la tête du patient !
Ah ah ah quel bel hôpital !
*rire*
*incompréhention* & *questionnement*
C'est incensé... J'ai compris, il faut tourner la tête
Je vais vous montrer :
En fait c'est une illusion d'optique, mais ils ont oublié de tourner la photo avant de la poster sur le site.
En réalité, si vous tournez l'image à 45°, vous avez une illusion d'optique !
Mais même pas Mec! Ça se voit totalement que le sol c'est ça !
P*tain téma est-ce que t'as déjà vu un mur de cette couleur ?!
Bah non même pas Mec, c'est parce que y'a pas de sol du coup...
Bah j'ai pas compris qu'est-ce qu'ils ont tenté de faire...?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce binz ? Ça veut dire quoi ?
Mais c'est complètement con ! Il y a pas de sol sous le canap' du coup ça ne marche pas
Oh p*tain mec je me prends la tête là !
Mec, j'aimerais lire le japonais...
Juste pour lire ce qu'il y a sur ce papier là!
Pour pouvoir comprendre les animés en VO? J'm'en bat les cou*lles !
Pour pouvoir acheter les manga au japon et quand même pouvoir les lire? bat les cou*lles !!
J'aimerais parler japonais juste pour pouvoir lire ce qu'il y a marqué sur ce petit papier !
Eh si y'a des gens qui parlent japonais dites-nous, hein !
OULA !
*Musique ÉPIQUE*
Ok, ici ils on tentés la blague du "inception", qui marche pas trop.
*Inspiration*
Mais où on en est ?
Si quelqu'un, sur cette planète,
arrive à caler cette image pour illustrer l'une de ces miniatures ou articles,
Eh bah il gagne ce studio, allez je me casse, salut !
En vrai, on dirais pas,
mais c'est dur d'avoir des bonnes idées pour faire du WTF comme ça !
Là encore ça va y'a du sens : elle lui fais des petites brochettes, elle prends soin de lui,
il est à l'hôpital depuis 3 mois, il a un très très gros rhume, bon voilà !
Là...  *rire*
Par exemple cette photo-là a un peu moins de sens...
Balader une pomme avec un bras de GodZilla c'est étrange elle est incroyable celle là, elle est folle !
Alors! Qu'est-ce-que vous m'avez trouvé comme titre pour cette image là ?
"Fast And Compote" ...Pas Mal. "Japon LES FRUITS A MOBILITE REDUITE ON NE LES OUBLIE PAS"
C'est beau Amixem ce que tu dis p*tain!
"Apple Va Mal!" C'est beau ça !
"C'est décidément très difficile de se masturber devant ces images"
* rire *
J'avoue c'est plus simple de se masturber devant celle-là par exemple
"Qu'est-ce qui est jaune et qui pousse une pomme ?"
*le silence accompagne ce malaise*
Nan, Nan... Nan, mais nan.
Ok, Image suivante!
*Han!* Mais qu'est-ce qui ce passe là ?
Qu'est-ce qui ce passe ?? *Il Sourit*
Mais est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un message vulgarisé a travers cette image
Donnant de l'importance au fruits
Mec, c'est sûr et certain,
Ils ont juste loué un décor d'hopîtal,
et ils ont essayé de faire le plus de trucs CON avec ce qu'il y avait autour d'eux !
Mais MEC, ça marche pas à chaque fois quoi !
OH! le Bon FaceSwap ! C'est bon ça !
On avait envie de voir les rôles qui s'inversent un peu là!
P*tain mais Mec, je pense vraiment,
qu'avec toutes ces images, on pourrait faire une BD !
On pourrait faire une vraie histoire !
Y'a toutes les situations possibles !
Mec, tu peux totalement faire une histoire, c'est fou !
OH ! Elle est un peu stylée celle-là !
Elle mérite de la mettre en fond d'écran, je suis désolé! ...
Voooiiilà! Elle est tellement belle !
Nan mais arrêtez avec ça!
La viande crue sur le bras nu, on arrête tout de suite !
Ça on veut bien, y'a pas de soucis !
Et cette personne en fond, au casque jaune ne se pose aucune question
par rapport à ce qui se passe à 10 mètres d'elle.
Donc c'est dans la catégorie "Echec et abandon de travail" !
N'oubliez pas :
Si vous voulez changer de vie, arrêter  du jour au lendemain,
Accrochez une seringue au bout d'un fil de fer relié à votre tête: le message est clair.
"Infirmère a un visage douteux depuis que j'ai vu mon genou"
Mais qu'est-ce que tu vas faire de cette image...?
"Les infirmières ont trouvé un chataîgnier"
*rire*
Hey mais Mec, j'te jure, regardez ces trois images :
(1) "Elle trouve une chataîgne"
(2) puis "Elle s'apprête à la ramasser"
(3) puis "Elle abandonne et s'en va  :'( "
Tu peux faire une bande dessinée !
Mais Mec, j'te jure : on a un concept !
"Infirmière montrant son courage et de coupe des ciseaux dans la bouche"
Ça, c'est le visage que tu fais quand tu montres ton courage...
...si je comprends bien...
Mec, j'ai eu très peu de courage dans ma vie...  très, très peu...
Celle-là elle part sur Twitter, celle-là!  J'la livre !
"PRANK : je me coupe la langue!"
En fait, j'trouve que, à force, les parodies de titres Putaclics c'est plus du tout drôle !
Nan ça devient un peu comme le mot "malaisant", t'as plus du tout envie de le dire !
*en profonde réflexion* Est-ce que du coup on devient des cons, à trouver ça nul ?
Parce-que tout le monde se met à le faire ?
Mais qui, du coup, est le vrai con ?
Celui qui fait ce que tout le monde fait ?
...Ou celui qui critique un truc parce que tout le monde le fait ?
*JCVD* À méditer, hein !
Ce débat ne doit pas avoir lieu dans cette vidéo.
Vidéo dans laquelle nous voyons des images comme celle-ci, ça ne va pas !
"Je donne ma langue au chat"
Oh, pas maaal !
Ooh p*tain ! Oh on finit par la plus belle !!
L'infirmière qui souffle dans un gros coquillaaaage !!
C'est un grand  O U I  !
*clap* *clap* *clap* *clap*
*ému*   Magnigifique.
Et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur la banque d'images en ligne la plus BIZARRE! ...
de la Planète !
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu ! ^^
Mec, ça doit être génial, quand ton métier c'est :
- louer un endroît,
- mettre deux personnes dedans,
- et leur dire de faire QUE D'LA M*RDE !
Mais ce qu'est bien dans tout ça c'est que je saurai où aller pour trouver des images pour mes miniatures :)
Allez, à bientôt ! Là j'crois qu'on est parfaitement dans le thème du... *rire*
*rire*
*poum, poum, poum* *musique de fin* *poum, poum, poum*